The adaptive vertebrate immune system
is one of the most amazingly complex
products of evolution that I know of and
at its heart is the process of clonal
selection of Antigen receptors.
It provides the conceptual
framework of adaptive immunity.
Every T or B cell bears a single type
of antigen receptor that has a unique
specificity. When a foreign
antigen binds to a receptor,
it activates that lymphocyte.
The lymphocyte then multiplies to form
a clone of effector cells that have
identical receptor specificity.
Lymphocytes that have affinity for self
antigen are deleted early in development
and that largely prevents
autoimmune disease.
Here is a first picture of
how clonal selection works.
So on the left side we see
a single progenitor cell.
It gives rise to many lymphocytes.
They undergo somatic recombination
so that each of them is expressing a
different antibody and that you can
see by the array of colors there.
On the left hand side,
somatic recombination is being done by
shuffling these inherited gene segments.
These exists as gene families and at each
of the low psi there are many illegals,
president of the comp in the population.
So every individual is
usually heterozygous for many
of these low psi and that
is what generates the recombinatorial
power of this process of first generating
a huge amount of diversity
and then selecting on it
during this process,
the cells that are
expressing self antigen,
they could cause autoimmune diseases
are eliminated and that gives a pool of
mature naive lymphocytes,
which potentially could react with
foreign antigens but not with self.
Then they encounter a foreign
antigen and one of them,
the purple one in this case actually
expresses an antibody that binds to it,
is then activated and multiplies and
it forms a clone of effector cells.
And the fact that each of
them is expressing that
specific antibody is indicated
by the fact that all of
these are purple here.
So the chains that are
produced are appearing to form
a unique receptor for each
lymphocyte.
You can see that this
lymphocyte is expressing
exactly the same receptor on its
surface.
This is a different lymphocyte with a
different set of somatically recombined
proteins,
somatically recombined producing
proteins which are being expressed on the
surface of this different lymphocyte.
The lymphocyte antigen receptors in
mammals are generated by somatic gene
rearrangements,
gene conversion,
nucleotide additions at the ends of
gene segments and random pairing of two
polypeptides to form antigen
receptors are antibodies.
These random processes produce this
initial huge array of diverse receptors
which look like this. Okay, so
let's recap antibody structure here.
We've seen it before.
An antibody is a y shaped protein.
It is extruded from the cell.
It's sitting on the surface of a cell
and exposed to the outside yet binds to a
particular antigen with a region that
contains both a variable light chain and a
variable heavy chain.
So these are the two parts of
this molecule which exist in gene.
Many forms in gene families in coated
in gene families in the genome and who
somatic recombination then determines
the diversity of antibodies available.
Okay?
No antibodies defend
their hosts in three ways.
They bind directly to viruses
into bacterial toxins,
preventing the entry of viruses into
cells and damping the activity of toxins.
They coat the surface of pathogens that's
called opsonization so that they can
then be eaten and killed by macrophages.
This is also done by compliment.
Yeah,
they activate complement proteins,
so they triggered this activation and
the compliment then compliments the
activity of the antibodies and coating
extracellular pathogens for consumption
by macrophages.
Okay,
so this is what makes blood plasma such
a dangerous environment for pathogens.
However,
intracellular parasites,
those not in the bloodstream
require special treatment.
Cell's infected by viruses use MHC one
molecules to present viral fragments on
their surface that activate cytotoxic
t cells that kill the cells that are
infected by the viruses.
Yeah,
macrophages that ingest leprosy
or tuberculosis pathogens.
Both of those are bacteria use MHC two
molecules to transfer bacterial fragments
to their surface where they recruit
helper t cells that detect the antigen and
presented to be cells.
Those B cells are then recruited and
magnified by clonal selection to produce
huge quantities of specific antibodies.
There are several
immune defense strategies.
First, kill bacterial and fungal
pathogens. With phagocytes,
anti microbial peptides and proteins, and
the compliment system, in other words,
eat poison or smother them.
Secondly,
eliminate infected cells
with cytotoxic lymphocytes.
These are typically virally infected
cells and cells that are infected with
intracellular bacteria and protozoa.
Third,
expel multicellular parasites
by Mucosal Epithelia,
mass cells and basophils.
Yeah.
All of these defenses
have associated costs.
Okay.
Each has its own associated
immunopathology and corresponding types of
autoimmune and allergic disease.
Type one immune responses are
PR are associated with allergy.
That's Immunoglobulin e
and mass cell mediated.
Yeah,
so for example,
this includes food allergies and asthma.
Type two immune responses.
Cytotoxic.
This is our mediated by lymphocytes
by compliment and antibody,
and that can result in autoimmune
hemolytic anemia and in thrombocytopenia.
Okay.
Type three immune responses are
mediated by the immune complex.
So this is the antibody antigen complex
and results in diseases like rheumatoid
arthritis and Lupus.
Yeah.
Type four immune response
is t-cell mediated and it,
it's vulnerability.
It's caused is multiple sclerosis.
Okay,
so to summarize,
adaptive immunity increases the range
of protection against pathogens and it
adds memory.
Okay.
Clonal selection produces
large populations of cells
that can produce antibodies
with identical specificity
in large quantities.
Yeah.
Intracellular parasites
get special treatment.
Antibodies have multiple functions.
Each defense strategy has corresponding
types of autoimmune and allergic
diseases.